bonjour ça nabli
bonjour bonjour merci beaucoup affront
direct avec nous ce matin dans la
matinale verte et france pour faire un
point sanitaire tout d'abord sur la
grande bretagne comme il ya quinze jours
d'écart avec la france ça nous donne des
indications précieuses qu'en est il de
la vague omicron est ce que le pays a
enfin atteint un pic
oui on voit que le nombre d'infections a
home écran ici à londres est en train de
diminuer ce nombre d'infections est en
train de diminuer et aussi en est en
train de voir que
cette infection n'a pas été une
infection très importante ou graves
c'est une infection qui a été très
augmenté en nombre mais en gravité c'est
pas une infection qui a été assez
exceptionnelle dans ce sens donc on a
rarement vu des malades qu'on devrait
adresser à l'hôpital
donc ça veut dire que les hôpitaux n'ont
pas été saturés comme le craignent
d'ailleurs la plupart des pays
absolument sion voir la courbe de
l'hospitalisation remarque une légère
augmentation de nombre
d'hospitalisations mais la chose la plus
importante c'est le nombre de lits de
personnes qui ont été ventilés ce nombre
de lits n'a pas augmenté et même il a un
tout petit peu diminué ceci sachant le
nombre d'infections est important qu'on
a eu oui donc proportionnellement on
peut dire que le vario mikron est moins
virulent c'est ce que confirme
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui la plupart des
experts est ce que ça nous permet d'être
optimiste pour la suite
oui absolument moi je pense qu'on doit
être très optimiste on a vu cette
infection qui est presque une infection
banale parfois je suis obligé d'utiliser
un test pour me dire si c'est à nos
écrans ou une grippe
pour faire la différence parce que de
cliniquement les signes se rapproche
énormément l'un de l'autre et les
patients eux aussi qu après les premiers
jours où il était un tout petit peu
affolée de savoir que cette grille ils
se sont vus peu cette infection n'est
pas très importante
et ils ont arrêté d'être inquiet je vois
des familles ou ya il n'y a pas une
seule personne qui à succès tom écran il
ya deux ou trois personnes par famille
qui en cet homme écran et c'est là à la
suite de l'autre la premiers sont un peu
inquiet ensuite lee est il vraiment le
demande même plus de consulter ou
d'avoir un avis quoique ce soit partisan
déjà vu que c'est une banale est ce que
justement alors l'espagne a commencé à
en discuter à ce qu'on peut on pourrait
envisager de classer cette pandémie
comme le dire un certain experts
britanniques de classer cette pandémie
en un an et demi comme comme c'est le
cas pour la grippe d'ailleurs
écouter et les il ya des cas qui sont
asymptomatiques c'est dire qu'ils n'ont
aucun symptôme c'est des gens qui
voulaient partir en vacances à cause des
fêtes de noël et qui lorsqu'ils ont fait
1-1 pcr ils ont prouvé qu'ils sont
positifs ça et un 2 2 la plupart des cas
c'est un mal à la gorge un héron
congestionné température mal à la tête
et on crée un prélèvement pour savoir qu
est ce que c est ce que c'est un corona
et ceci pour essayer d'isoler les gens
et caetera
et parfois on trouve c'est un coroner
parfois on trouve il n'y a pas de corona
et parfois en confiant que c'est un
virus
de l'accueil il n'y a pas eu autant de
restrictions outre-manche que ces cas en
france vous pensé que c'était une
c'était bien de laisser la population
être responsable finalement elle même de
de la situation
à écouter comme vous le savez très bien
si on fait des risques ayant tué et on
les respecte bah c'est pas cessé c'est
autant la même chose mais moi je trouve
que les gens sont très
écouteurs il essaie d'appliquer toujours
les restrictions pour éviter que les
hôpitaux soient
hyper plat et hyper congestionné et
favoriser la perte de la vie donc les
gens ici à londres sont
respectueux des des lois et essayer de
les respecter si on arrive à une station
de bus on se met en ligne en attend les
autres de passer avant donc il ya
toujours un respect de l'autre et une
compliance assez importante à lier notre
population est vaccinée de l'ordre de
95% avec la troisième maison + 1
beaucoup plus absolument lui ment et le
ministre pour pardon je vous coupe la
parole le premier ministre britannique
lui qui assiste à une fête alors qu' il
y avait un confinement en grande
bretagne qu'en pensez vous
écoutez les britanniques ici sont pas
très contents d'entendre ça donc ils
disent que eux ils étaient très isolé la
en essayant de ne pas sortir toute
réunion plus qu'une personne n'était pas
autorisée et les gens ne sont pas
contents bailleur ya une commission
denquête qui est à lancé et moi je pense
que le premier ministre s'il s'avère
qu'il est absolument mais bien qu'il a
il a confirmé qui s'est uni laïque
s'étaient ils savaient y semer une
hêtraie de travail ou une réunion de
travail
non il y aura obligé de payer les pots
et semé à certains demandant même sa
démission
oui mais bon la question qui se pose est
ce qu'il ya un autre pilote parmi
l'équipage
on verra cela merci beaucoup en tout cas
ça nabli d'avoir fait un point sur la
situation dans votre pays ce matin en
direct dans la matinale de rtl france